[Music]
there good evening I'm under Stuart bran
from the long now foundation looking at
this film we thought well you know we
could do a 400 foot high hourglass
inside the mountain in Eastern Nevada
and then you start thinking actually you
could have a bunch of year hourglasses
decade hourglasses century hourglasses
and they feed and they add up and you'd
always know where you were in the 10,000
year time frame so far we're not doing
that but we know who to hire and tonight
you have a very highly esteemed
biologist who breaks a bit of well it
breaks a number of molds one of them is
I've known James Lovelock and his Gaia
hypothesis for a long time and Lovelock
used to complain that climatologists
were very interested in the in Gaia
theory and geologists became interested
very early in Gaia theory the idea of
Earth is a self-regulating quasi mega
organism but that biologists hated the
idea of Gaia thought it was just so much
new-age drivel and pay no attention to
James Lovelock our speaker tonight takes
Gaia very seriously is laced through his
book and I expect we'll be hearing about
it tonight Tim Flannery
thanks so much Stuart for organizing
this event and for wearing your Ozzie
hat when you introduced me I guess I
should have brought mine along but a
month on the road sir a bit too long to
be carrying your eyes II have with you
every day but um look I'm really
delighted to be here particularly for
this this kind of seminar series where
it seems to me that you calibrate the
response that's required to the problems
we face at the appropriate level the
long now level taking a bit of a
longer-term view and this book that I
would spent the last five years writing
takes that that longer view but it arose
out of rather immediate questions that
people have been asking me for the last
several years or last decade really ever
since I've become involved with climate
change and the questions generally took
the form of or what chance have we got
it is a too late are we doomed as a
species to suffer dangerous climate
change and and what's our future in
terms of the population problems we have
the food security and water problems in
the face of climate change the only way
that I could think of going about giving
a proper answer or an adequate answer to
those questions was to go back to the
earth system itself and to try to
understand how it's been formed how it
actually works
what powers it and to go back to our own
species and to understand a little bit
more about us because it's at the
intersection of our species and the
planetary system that these problems all
arise so that's the the book it's um
this is the Australian cover it's not
the one you'll see here my American
publisher looked at that and just said
yeah it looks too much like the cover of
Watchtower magazine we're not having
that in America and and I fear he is
probably right but my Australian
publisher wanted something that said you
know serious thought to an Australian
audience so that's that's what the
clouds are all about for us
rather than some really just sort of
thing but anyway that's it's a warning
to any budding publishers in Gnome room
you do
be a bit careful about he covers not the
knee control everything but the the work
I did with with writing the book really
took me back to to this man here because
he was the man who explained for the
first time how we were created and how
life on earth in all its diversity was
formed that's Charles Darwin's tombstone
it's in Westminster Abbey and I love the
way the British deal with this stuff
they've you know collected all of their
famous dead people and put them in this
ancestor house and classified them so
all the poet's are together and the
playwright's and you know the scientists
but Charles Darwin you wouldn't know why
he's in there look at the gravestone
it's the only one that doesn't really
tell you why what he achieved why is in
the great house tambourine as we'd call
Danny New Guinea or ancestor house and
that is because the ideas that he
produced were not just of scientific
importance they had an extraordinarily
profound effect on the society that
Darwin was part of and continued to
resonate into our own times
really what what Darwin discovered was
extraordinarily simple it was it was
just that in any population there is
variation between the individuals that
some of those individuals will find
themselves better suited to the
conditions that they they're living in
than others and therefore are likely to
leave more offspring and that over the
vastness of geological time as it was
just being discovered in in Darwin's age
that simple process is capable of
creating all of the diversity that we
see the biological diversity that we see
on planet earth simple elegant
undisputable really as a sort of an idea
and yet Darwin sat on it for 20 years
before he'd release it and I was
interested to know why why that was and
in pursuing that question I went to
Darwin's home he's most of his that
awful life was spent at downe house in
and this is the famous sand walk beside
his house which is now a sort of a
shrine to science really and it took me
a while to find this sand walk because
as you can see there's no sand on it
it's all pebbles why Darwin the great
site is called it the sand walk instead
of the pebble walk you know geologists
actually do discriminate between sand
and pebbles but anyway it was the pillar
I found it was even covered in pebbles
in Darwin's day but the reason that the
sand walk is important is that it was
Darwin's habit to spend several hours
every day walking around this sand walk
through the forest and the sand walks
shaped pretty much like a racetrack it's
just a big oval and as I walked around
at trying to peer into the mind of this
great man a bit I'd read some
biographies by his children are of him
and had read the scientific received
wisdom about the idea the idea the
received wisdom is incidentally that
Darwin would walk around the sand walk
trying to perfect his complex ideas
about evolutionary theory and trying to
perhaps craft beautiful sentences and
paragraphs to convey his ideas to them
to the general public I don't think that
was the case because I his children
write about playing in the woods there
maybe they were playing ball or cowboys
and Indians I don't know what they
played in those days but whatever it was
they did interrupt their father quite
frequently and Darwin always welcome to
the interaction and that's not the
reaction of a man who is deep in thought
about a particular issue I think what
Darwin was doing on a sand walk was
fingering metaphorically speaking his
worry beads he was thinking about the
impacts of this simple idea on his
society and at the heart of that process
of us thinking about the impacts was
really the idea that what he was going
to be telling people was that they were
not the creations of a loving caring God
with his individual stake in em but were
instead the creations of an unspeakably
cruel and amoral process and that that
knowledge may see both hope and charity
perish along with faith in his society I
think that was his base
Woori he sat on the idea for twenty
years as a result of that and it was
really only this man here Alfred Russel
Wallace that forced Darwin to publish
Wallace was as different from Darwin as
as anyone could be Darwin was
middle-class married well accepted into
the British establishment a careful
reductionist scientist a man of infinite
patience of great orderly of orderliness
of mind Wallace in contrast was a
working-class lad finish school early
because his family couldn't afford to
send him through school went off to the
tropics to became become a collector of
biological specimens and while he was on
the island of turn arte in 1858 in
what's now eastern Indonesia he suffered
an attack of malaria and in the middle
of that attack had a vision of how
species were created he when he
recovered he wrote his ideas down in a
letter to Darwin asking that these ideas
be published in a scientific journal and
when Darwin opened the letter he just
about died in a ditch as we say in
Australia he was deeply shocked because
he said you know this guy I couldn't
have made a better summary of my ideas
if he'd had my notes in front of him
Darwin in despair wrote to a friend a
very influential scientific friend
asking for advice and the friend said
will write up write something up really
quickly just a just a few a few words
few hundred words and we'll publish both
papers together and that's what happened
on the 25th of July 1858 the Linnaean
Society of London Journal published both
of those papers neither man could be
there for the reading of the paper and
be there with his peers to explain it
Wallace of course because he was still
in Indonesia Darwin because the full
force of this awful mechanism here
discovered was manifesting itself to him
he was by the graveside of his 18 month
old son namesake Charles Robert Darwin
who died in infancy
and furthermore darwin's wife Emma
Darwin who was a deeply religious woman
her only consolation that day surely was
the consolation of religion and I can
only imagine the turmoil endowments mind
as he stood by the graveside knowing
full well that his words were being read
out to the world that would dispel for
many that consolation as it turns out he
needn't have worried quite so much
because uh no one took any notice of
either paper the president of the
president of the surface society that
published those two papers Thomas Bell
who was an expert on the stork eyed
Crustacea among other things summarized
the results published in the journal at
the end of that year saying nothing had
happened to revolutionize in any way any
aspect of science in the journals rather
boring year missing entirely the
importance of this fundamental idea that
had been published what changed was the
following year when Darwin published his
book which he characterized as one long
argument on the Origin of Species with
the subtitle part of the subtitle
reading and on the preservation of
favoured races Darwin I think was a
little naive when he published that
title because if I was going into a
bookshop in mid 19th century England to
look at books and saw something titled
on the preservation of favoured races I
don't think I'd be thinking about worms
or were just a little bit better being
worms than other worms you know which is
what Darwin meant I would have been
thinking about the British Empire
builders had an India and the the
British upper class the favored races
and so the idea was taken up despite the
fact that the book doesn't talk about
human society others very quickly took
the idea up Herbert Spencer one of the
great social scientists coined the term
survival of the fittest to try to
explain what Darwin's theory meant for
society and out of that came a whole
discipline a scientific discipline
that's still alive and well well you
know in our universities today in the
form of reductionist Darwinian science
and the Oh Darwinian side
which is a very valuable field of
enterprise but also these unfortunate
social experiments among them was the
rise of National Socialism in Germany in
the early 20th century the the spread of
eugenics societies around the world
based on a sort of a Darwinian
understanding and also I'd argue the
establishment of disciplines such as
neoclassical economics that argue that a
free market is in the interest of the
individual if you believe you live in a
survival of the fittest world a
dog-eat-dog world those sort of things
make sense to you the limits to that
reductionist scientific approach however
came home to me very clearly when I was
reading Richard Dawkins as work Richard
Dawkins is a great neo-darwinian thinker
and he has brought enormous insight to
understanding evolutions mechanism but
it was when I was reading Darwin on
motherhood that I realized how limited
that philosophy is as an attempt to
explain the world we live in
he wrote something like you know the
smile of a baby really is an attempt to
trick the mother into giving it more
resources than its siblings you know and
and I thought Richard you you kind of
write at a some sort of level maybe some
evolutionary level but what you've just
written tells me nothing about the love
between a mother and a child
it is utterly inadequate to under - for
us to comprehend the complex world we
live in and I really think that that's
because what Darwinian thinking has done
has elucidated beautifully the mechanism
that created us it tells us nothing
whatsoever about the legacy that that
mechanism has left behind and the person
who explained the legacy of that
mechanism at the very beginning and
better than anyone else was this man
Alfred Russel Wallace at the age of 80
in 1904 he published one of the most
important books I think to be published
in the 20th century it was called man's
place in the universe another curious
subtitle it's a study of the I think
it's the the the unity or plurality of
worlds what the hell is he on about
they're basically his argument was that
that earth is the only living planet all
of the other planets are dead
the book is the foundation text for the
science of astrobiology it is a
forerunner of jove james Lovelock's work
on on gaia
because in it he discusses the
atmosphere the nature of the atmosphere
the importance of life in creating the
atmosphere and regulating the planets
weather systems and so forth and he also
talks about the horror that is air
pollution or was air pollution in
britain at the time the fact that this
is standing the bodies of countless
working-class children and it tells you
a little bit about why Wallis was
forgotten if Darwin was of the
establishment and fortified the
establishment view and justified the
unjustified and justifiable that the
establishment would like to have
justified Wallace was the opposite he
was someone who understood injustice
deeply resented it greatly and was
hoping for a better world but most of
all what his book pointed out was that
the legacy of the evolutionary process
is not a survival of the fittest world
but a world of enormous complexity and
interrelatedness and codependence the
extent of Wallace's message is still
being understood by scientists I just
want to point out very few examples here
this is these are mitochondria they're
the Power Packs of ourselves they're in
every one of our cells and yet they are
not of us
these organelles began life as
independent free living bacteria in an
ancient ocean a billion years ago and
came to live in ourselves
in much the same way that that the algae
today live in coral polyps so this was a
symbiosis at the beginning after a
billion years of evolution by natural
selection these mitochondria and us are
effectively one it took science well
until only two probably 20 years ago to
discover these things even had a
separate origin we can't exist without
them for a millisecond and they cannot
exist without us that's the power of
coevolution but if you look at our
bodies they offer many more examples
and that of coevolution you know my skin
is covered in hundreds of species of
bacteria and fungi and viruses I mean I
wash no I am an Ozzy but I do wash so
don't worry about that but but I can't
live without the things every one of us
is the same
I mean fully ten percent of our weight
is not us at all it is other species and
some of them are quite big you know
there there are mites that live only on
the human eyebrows there are other
species that live just at the base of
the human eyelashes our God is full of
alien species and some of the ones that
live there were quite large things like
hook worms and we depend upon them all
it's recently been shown for example at
hookworm with the eradication of
hookworm in developed societies we are
now suffering a rise in autoimmune
diseases such as Crohn's disease that
destroy the bowel Pete you can buy hook
worm eggs commercially now on the
internet if you've got Crohn's disease
to reinfect yourself with this what was
thought of as a parasite in fact as a
symbiont and it's part of this great
great it's part of this great ecological
complexity of thousands of species that
we call us right we are ecosystems of
mere planetary complexity indispensably
tied with thousands of things that are
not asked that form this thing we call
us so that's the that's the
co-evolutionary message at the bodily
level it is an incredibly complex world
of interdependence E and that
interdependence E I don't draw back from
telling you that it goes from everything
from the mitochondria to the hookworm to
the thing we call love between people
all of that everything we see that is
either living or a manifestation of life
is a result of the evolutionary process
has been made by evolution by natural
selection so what has the evolutionary
process created at the largest level
what is Gaia
what is this thing James Lovelock called
Gaia they're the they're the thing is
there we know that almost nothing comes
in but sunlight almost nothing goes out
but heat and that the energy harvested
from the sunlight is an enormous energy
budget 100 Terra
what's that that's how much energy life
commands and it is that energy budget is
put to creating this thing how was it
created well it's pretty I think pretty
straightforward you know the that little
message at the bottom there tells you
information systems organized matter
right so the DNA that that is the
blueprint for my body has organized all
this matter into my body right the DNA
of life as a whole has organized the
matter of the earth into that particular
body and the imprint of life is deep
there's Africa a continent until I
research this book I've always thought
of the rocks as being somehow separate
from life what I've discovered
subsequently is that the continental
rocks themselves are a manifestation of
life in part it's an extraordinary
concept published in a respect reputable
journal just two years ago scientists
looking at the early history of the
earth understanding that the continental
rocks had arrived from the erosion of
oceanic rocks knowing about the energy
budget of the early Earth and knowing
that there just wasn't enough energy in
the system to create the continents at
the time they were created and at the
scale they were created there had to be
an extra energy force involved the only
possibility these scientists point out
is life itself
life was even then capturing energy
making compounds such as acids that
hastened the erosion of the oceanic
rocks and gave birth to the rocks
beneath our feet to the continents and
of course the continents changed
everything
they continental drift opens mid-ocean
ridges in the oceanic system and the
seawater thought the entire waters of
the ocean passed through those mid-ocean
ridges every 30 to 40 million years and
it's that process that regulates the
saltiness of the sea that's why the sea
doesn't keep on getting saltier when we
go to the oceans we've known for a long
time that the oceans were created in
their current form by life that prior to
2 billion years ago they were full of
heavy metals and other toxins and that
living things used those metals as
catalysts for their ins ionic reactions
when those living things died they fell
to the bottom of the ocean and so were
formed many of the great mineral
deposits the gold deposits that copper
deposits the iron deposits and so forth
that we dig up today the atmosphere will
Lovelock and wallace even knew that is a
manifestation of life every bit as much
as a bird's feather is a manifestation
of life of a bird a single individual
bird the difference is that the
atmosphere is the manifestation of life
as a whole 99% of the gases in the
atmosphere
Lovelock argues our recreation of life
the only exceptions the 1% that's noble
gases so information systems organize
matter over four billion years the
infant the digital information system as
DNA has organized the matter of the
planet in a very particular way and that
particular outcome has been to stabilize
conditions of the surface of the earth
to make it habitable for life itself
that's what life tends to do that's what
the information systems are tend to do
but Earth is not like a body it's not
like my body or your body because it
lacks a command and control system it
doesn't have a brain what it does have
is what I've called Geo pheromones that
operates someone like the pheromones
that that regulate ant colonies and
those geo pheromones include the
greenhouse gases atmospheric dust things
like missile sulphonic acid and so forth
that um in minut concentrations cause
systemic changes in the Earth's system I
just want to go from the earth system
now to the third hierarchical level
created by the information system we
call DNA so we've got the body with its
command and control system the organism
in other words we have the planetary
system which is a loose confederation of
living things I call it a Commonwealth
of virtue because every species takes in
the washing of every other and the
system keeps going around but there's a
third level of organization present on
planet earth and IO Wilson ed Wilson is
really the great
expert in this and that is called the
super organism a super organism is a
level of organization intermediate
between that of an organism and an
ecosystem or the planet as a whole this
is a great example these what you see
before you were cockroaches that a
hundred million years ago discovered
agriculture and became termites the
cockroach has always seemed to be ahead
of us I don't know how but there are a
hundred million years ahead of us in
this case and they build cities
cockroaches that discovered agriculture
like humans that discovered agriculture
have built great civilizations without
the use of reason they're part an
outcome of the evolutionary process so
we see here a a termite city it's like a
skyscraper it has its own air
conditioning systems its own water
supply systems its own highways byways
are the road systems it's got its own
mortuaries its food stores its gardens
and everything else garbage dumps
everything else that a city needs to
function and here are the little
inhabitants of the city on the side
there you can see that they they vary
one from the other even though they are
each other's closest relatives and we
will come back to that but but part of
the reason is that the social insects
have discovered the virtues of the
division of labor and so they divide
labor up as I've said whom the human
humans have also formed a super organism
over the last 10,000 years we're far
behind the social insects which include
the termites the bees and the ends but
we are on our way what can we learn from
the insects the insects differ from us
in one fundamental way in an insect
super organism
each individual is the other is very
closely related to every other
individual in the group and in the most
primitive insect super organisms all of
them have a reason from species that are
monogamous and I find it interesting
that humans also a quite monogamous
wherever that may lead us but the reason
that the insects have to be monogamous
or a single Queen mating with a single
drone
is that genetic glue is all that holds
the insects super organism together at
the early stages of its development as
the insects super organisms become more
complex and we get that so the large at
announce the leafcutter ants that can
have ain´t million individuals in their
colony and forty different working
castes and in that that's a status of
civilization on the scale of Elizabethan
England doesn't have Shakespeare but
it's got a level or else the thing about
those very complex insects super
organisms is that they have more genetic
diversity they permit more genetic
diversity than the more primitive insect
super organisms and that occurs because
a single queen will mate with several
males taking the sperm from several
males therefore giving the colony more
genetic diversity and giving it the
potential to diversify its worker caste
for example in a way that can't happen
in the more simple colonies humans are
not genetically closely related enough
for genetics to form the glue that holds
our super organism together but we are
remarkably genetically similar this last
month the human population reached 7
billion and there is less genetic
diversity in the seven billion of us
than there is in any random sample of 50
chimpanzees from West Africa yeah and
that is the case simply because our
species nearly went extinct 70,000 years
ago the Lake Toba eruption and a
volcanic eruption in Indonesia reduced
the human population to a few thousand
individuals and so we are similar at
that level and that similarity is not
enough to hold the super organism
together but it is enough to ensure that
a smile is understood as a smile
throughout the human species that we
have a fundamental underlying humanity
that we can instantly recognize in each
other so how did the human super
organism grow and form and what is the
glue that holds it together we see here
the five separate human super organisms
that formed independently beginning
about eleven thousand years ago and I
find this incredible Jared Diamond talks
about
but you know how is it that in the whole
history of the planet
no warm-blooded creature has formed a
super organism until ten thousand years
ago when one species our species does it
five times independently Fertile
Crescent eleven thousand years ago
domestication of wheat was a major
breakthrough East Asia 2,000 years later
millet and rice form the basis of
another super organism at least ten
thousand years ago in the highlands of
New Guinea the the domestication of taro
and sugarcane led to another and then in
the Americas entirely independently
about 5,000 6,000 years ago other crops
leading to the development of yet more
human super organisms there are two
kinds of glue I think that hold super
organisms together one is the division
of labour an incredibly powerful form of
glue and if you think about human
civilization for the last thousand years
I mean our cities have been population
sinks because diseases spread so quickly
in them and conditions have been so
appalling in answer'd cities that life
expectancy was really short and yet
people kept flooding to the cities why
did they come to sit down at the table
of the division of labor and sup from
the benefits that other human beings
bring humans are our greatest resource
in in a you know in a super organism
where we can divide labor that is that
is self-evident and Adam Smith realized
that way back in the late 18th century
so that is an important element I'd like
to follow on thinking about this a
little bit in a second but the other
form of glue that is required is a
commonality of belief I think among
people and these societies have by and
large either had a tolerance of multiple
beliefs or a commonality of belief and I
guess you would call a tolerance of
other beliefs a belief in itself as
these five human super organisms have
come in contact there's been both good
and bad come of it but the one thing
that inevitably happens is trade in
ideas in materials in innovation and it
was Francis Bacon way back in the 17th
century that said you know what has made
Europe
it was gunpowder paper and the compass
all invented in China brought into
Europe changed the world just like to
talk a little bit about the way we
organize our superorganism and compare
it with that of the insects
it was Plato writing two and a half
thousand years ago that that talked
about an ideal human society in the
Republic very very interesting book and
he said in in the ideal Society there is
no difference between thine and mine and
that is exactly the situation in an ant
colony yeah because the interest of the
individual are perfectly concordant with
that of the insect civilization but we
are will fall selfish upright Apes and
despite the best efforts of Karl Marx
and the rest dyin and mine will always
be different to humans we are
differently constituted so the
challenges of holding together a super
organism and coordinating action between
selfish individuals is a very different
proposition from that of a society which
has genetics on its side I said that the
book arose from trying to answer those
questions and I may have seemed to have
wandered far from the questions I
started with but what we've learned so
far about the nature of our planet and
the nature of our species
lets us discern two possibilities I
think for a human future one is outlined
in this book by Peter Ward a great
friend of mine called the Medea
hypothesis
Peter argues that it is a characteristic
of life to destroy life the Medea
hypothesis is named incidentally for the
Greek mythical figure Medea who killed
her own children and ward argues that
the great extinction events release most
of the great extinction events of
Earth's history have come about when
life has been very successful so life is
very successful creates a buildup or an
imbalance in the greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere that then leads to a shift in
oceanic circulation that causes a great
extinction event and in in wards
mind the destruction of biodiversity as
we're seeing it at the moment and the
current human progress is entirely
concordant with Earth history
I think the Prost I think the hypothesis
rests on shaky foundations it rests on a
belief really in a survival of the
fittest world but we know that we do not
live in a survival of the fittest world
and the reason I say that just to think
about this in a slightly different way
imagine a football competition it's a
survival of the fittest called football
competition at the end of the season
you'd have a winner but you wouldn't
have a competition anymore there's only
be one team it's not the nature of the
world we live in we live in a world of
enormous diversity complexity and
cooperation it's not a survival of the
fittest world
so the Medea hypothesis I think is based
on a wrong concept of evolutions legacy
but also is built on an awareness of our
current environmental crisis and I can't
argue with that we are clearly in a
moment of crisis if we take the longer
view so what am i arguing in here on
earth as the book cover says it's an
argument for hope I'm not going to leave
this slide on for very long but I put it
up there just to simply let you know the
progress is being made on really
difficult environmental problems this
just explains the history of the
Stockholm convention to ban persistent
organic pollutants
these are things that once they're made
we know they're going to end up in our
bodies by 2004 banned under a very
rigorous treaty that banned outright the
production of these chemicals in
developed countries and mandated that
wealthy countries needed to fund efforts
to eradicate these chemicals in the
developing world and revised in August
last year
banning yet more dangerous persistent
organic pollutants the ozone hole
another great example in you know oh so
the ozone story is so interesting the
chemicals that were destroying the ozone
layer were finally banned from
production on a 16th of September 1987
in Montreal Canada by universal human
agreement under the treaty
I think that day is going to be the
first great global day of celebration
for the human species one day it was
really the first occasion when we acted
in our own self-interest together as a
species and this little graphic tells
you what was at stake there is I think
1990 1974
that's 2060 the Calabar tells you how
much ozone is about the blue end being
really bad news not much ozone and this
graphic tells you what would have
happened if the Montreal Protocol hadn't
been ratified by 2060 we would have been
living in a world in absolute crisis no
ozone means ultraviolet radiation
reaching the surface of the planet this
sort of sunburn we get in 20 minutes
outside on a sunny day today we'd get in
a matter of seconds for each percentage
increase in ultraviolet radiation
reaching the surface of the planet we
get a 1% increase in the failure of
crops to germinate and 1% increase in
blindness in anything with eyes
ultraviolet radiation tears apart our
DNA we have overcome that problem
there's the decline takes a long time to
register because these chemicals are
persistent take some five years to get
into the stratosphere we start to see
the decline even out and here's the good
news the ozone layer is recovering
despite years like this last one when we
have very low ozone concentrations over
the Arctic because of cold conditions
some really intractable difficult
problems have even been solved this one
is fantastic that diclofenac we called
it in Australia you call it Volterra and
I believe here any matters to the gap
will know that and anyone who suffers
any other inflammatory disease and will
know what Volterra knees it's a
widespread drug it's perfectly harmless
in US and any other mammals and most
other organisms it is invariably fatal
to vultures and we only discovered this
through the widespread veterinary use of
a voltaren in the Indian subcontinent
and East Asia as a whole eat these these
vultures were extremely common birds in
eastern South Asia up until the use of
Volterra Envy
any practices it turns out that if just
one cow carcass in a hundred contains
voltaren you will cause the extinction
of vultures and in the late 1990s early
2000 the vulture population of India
this is all vulture species was
declining faster than the dodo was
declining in the 17th century as it
headed towards extinction this was
having unfortunate consequences that
Parsi religion the adherence to the
Parsee religion bury their dead in
towers of silence you can still see them
in Mumbai
they believe it's wrong to pollute the
four main elements of the planet fire
earth air and water and so they prefer
to recycle dead bodies directly back
into the living into vultures with the
decline of vultures their mortuary
practices were severely challenged and
continue to be but even more seriously
for the Indian population as a whole the
number of dogs feral dogs increased
dramatically and there were very
widespread fears of a rabies epidemic
the way this was solved was
extraordinary
the Indian government banned voltaren is
a medical or veterinary drug but that
had zero impact because an Indian farmer
that had a sick cow he'd go along to his
doctor and say hey Doc my back's not all
that good you know can I have some
voltaren and of course he'd get his dose
any go home and give it to the cow it
turns out that there were other drugs
there were alternatives that could be
used but they were all more expensive
and it was only through concerted
community action from groups like the
center for environmental education in
India getting out there offering farmers
a rebate if they bought the more
expensive drug for their for the
treatment of their cattle that we've
started to turn the situation around the
the position for vultures is still very
perilous but we've now seen the return
of at least some vultures back to Mumbai
where the towers of silence are located
so that's an effort where just
individual good people got together to
make a difference we've still got an
enormous challenge ahead of us whether
we face a modeun end or a gay and future
that graph there with the different
colours on it all you need know about it
is that the the green
section is under exploited fisheries the
dark brown section at the bottom is
collapsed fisheries and there's a time
line going from 1950 to 2000 on it you
can see where we're headed you know it
is extraordinarily difficult for humans
to agree on regulating a global Commons
the atmosphere is one and we can talk a
bit about climate science later on and
how we're doing with that but the oceans
is another really really difficult area
to get agreement on land we're doing
much better
we have stopped or we're in a process of
stopping the destruction of the
rainforest now you know only a couple of
years ago was thought that there would
be no more round forest outside
protected areas by 2050 that has been
turned around by new satellite
surveillance and a renewed willingness
by countries working together to stop
the clearing of rain for us one of the
best examples of this is in the state of
Para in southern Brazil where a very
energetic governor using satellite data
tracked illegal clearing worked out
where the cattle from the cleared layers
were being sold to slaughter the
abattoirs and then work that who was
buying meat from those abattoirs and
slapped a billion dollar fines on on the
whole chain top to bottom it stops
nearly all clearing of rainforests very
effectively so we have the tools in some
instances to do something other problems
are more intractable so much hangs in
the balance
why do these things happen why do why do
people clear the forests that we depend
on why do we take such a short view of
so many problems very interesting
question
these guys here demonstrate part of the
answer these are Somali pirates young
men with nothing to lose who will take
enormous risks to try to get something
and it turns out that we all have a
phenomenon called a discount factor you
know in our minds social scientists have
tried to understand this and the way
they've done it by talking to students
and saying well I'll give you $100 right
now but you name a sum that you would
want to receive if I asked you to wait
for a year and it turns out young men
will often ask for $500 young women are
less greedy if you want they might
settle for $300
but why the difference and why the huge
amount after all if you took that
hundred dollars and put it in a bank for
you you'd only get $10 interest right we
have a huge discount factor of work the
reason that we are seemingly impatient
we want a lot for waiting I think is
that in our deep evolutionary past life
was very uncertain the chances I was
living for another year we're not as
high as they are today so it made sense
to take what you can get now taken to
its extreme young men who may be dead by
the age of 20 because they live in a in
some of the poorest suburbs and and most
drug infected suburbs in our
civilization have a very high chance of
dying or going to jail by the age of 20
and so they'll take anything they can
get today particularly if it'll get him
a girl because when you get down to this
level of human behavior you know where
people have nothing to lose it seems to
me that their genes take over and the
genes don't care about us as individuals
right our genes don't they just want us
to reproduce so if you as a young man
can get your genes into someone else by
getting a girl pregnant that's the way
out for the genes you know not for us
it's appalling we as a individual may
die but the genes get their way that all
changes when you give people something
to lose once we have something to lose
we can take a longer-term view and we do
you can see from what I'm trying to say
there that in a global human super
organism as we're currently forming the
battle to eradicate poverty is one of
the most urgent tasks we have because we
need to give people a longer timeframe
we need to give them a long now look at
things not the view that will see them
chop down the last tree just so they can
survive I'm really fascinated by what's
happening with our current global with
their current superorganism we've gone
from a tribal world where just over the
last few centuries the the the
superorganisms are allied in their
coming together into a world now where
we are interconnected individual to
individual in a way we never were before
there's 3.3 billion mobile phones on the
planet there is
internet connection is widely available
and what that is doing is allowing ideas
to flow very quickly from one individual
to the other and that is enormous ly
empowering of the individual the wave of
democratization I've seen in my life is
extraordinary I think that you know I
remember growing up in a world where
dictators were embedded in the heart of
Western Europe this is Egypt today we
can see the way these ideas Democratic
ideas flowing and I could just say I
just need to say here as well that for
selfish willful upright Apes democracy
is the only system that will never work
it empowers the individual is all put in
difficult as it is as Churchill said and
it's the worst possible system of
government except for every other system
that's been tried from time to time in
his world of woe of hours and it's
entirely true hard difficult but the
only practical system I think so where
is all of this leading us in terms of
our relationship with the planet is Gaia
itself changing as these changes occur
I've said several times we're greedy and
selfish does that mean we can't be a
global intelligence for planet Earth
well our brains tell us otherwise brains
are greedy and selfish brains use they
only weigh 20% of our 2% of our body
mass but they use 20% of the energy we
get from our food they are by definition
greedy they're also incredibly selfish
because brains will cut off resources to
any other organ in the body before they
they deprive themselves of one iota of
oxygen or nutrients they're just like us
they're greedy and selfish but their
great command and control systems for
the body because they adhere by one rule
that they cannot bankrupt a system upon
which they depend what is Gaia like and
what might gay be like in future as we
start to develop and change
James Lovelock believes that Gaia is
like an old lady
who has to share her house with a
growing and destructive group of
teenagers Gaia grows angry and if they
don't mend their ways
she'll evict them so that's his view
that the midian hypothesis is in fact
correct that we're headed
on a path to destruction I don't think
that's right I think that Gaia is much
more like a newborn infant after all a
newborn infant has a new form brain a
nervous system and a body but they yet
to be fully integrated so self-awareness
and self-consciousness are very limited
and that's the situation I think we're
eating we are in a world where we are
becoming interconnectedness
interconnected to the extent of forming
a global consciousness but this global
consciousness and the nervous system we
have in terms of our satellites of
violence and our agriculture and every
other interface with the living planet
with the body if you want he's still
being integrated and will take some time
to be integrated and of course infancy
and birth is the most dangerous period
in the life of any organism any entity
the ancient Greeks who coined the term
guy I really did believe the earth was a
perfect complete organism like ourselves
they thought the earth was a living
organism I mean it never has been but
maybe it has the chance in the deep
future to be just that as it gains a
command and control system I love that
idea that information organizes matter
and I just like to look at it on a
longer time frame this is a this is a
life bar of the gay an organism formed
4.5 billion years ago out of a cloud of
dust by 3.8 billion years ago life had
somehow appeared on the planet no one
knows how but everything we know about
it is that it had to have originated in
Earth's crust that all we are is walking
talking bits of Earth's crust ashes to
ashes dust to dust we've always known it
but it is absolutely true as true today
as it ever was we're not separate from
nature we're not separate from Gaia we
are of it we are a bit of the Earth's
crust by three billion years ago or so
life had taken control of the earth
system the energy budget was big enough
for that to be able to occur we start
seeing the profound transformation of
our planet into a living planet
by a hundred million years ago the first
super organisms have been created those
cockroaches that discovered agriculture
by ten thousand years ago the human
super organism the first intelligent
superorganism had begun to form what
does the future hold at the rate that we
can travel through space now it would
only take five billion years to colonize
the entire 5 million years to colonize
the entire galaxy for a paleontologist
that's not very long at all but whatever
the case there I think we can think of
Gaia the Earth System as having
reproduced reached puberty and
reproduced the moment that we colonize
another planet that timeframe also gives
us a sense I think of our chances
there's a wonderful paradox called
Fermi's paradox named and framed by an
Italian physicist Enrico Fermi and he
his paradox is really simple he looked
up at the Stars saw there was billions
of stars out there and thought you know
why the great silence why aren't we
hearing from other intelligent life it
is clear that the only form of life that
could potentially communicate with us is
an intelligent superorganism indigent
individuals can be as smart as they want
without the division of labour we will
never be able to achieve great things
it's possible that the Medea hypothesis
is right and that that life has an
intelligent superorganism in particular
carries within it the seeds of its own
destruction and that at the moment of
birth these entities tend to die that's
one possibility but that timeline gives
me a possibility another possibility
that's more optimistic and that is that
we genuinely are the first it took all
of time from the Big Bang up to that
moment just to create the elements that
are required to make life the heavy
elements carbon iron and so forth as
Carl Sagan said we're made of Stardust
the stuff that forms in the hearts of
stars it takes three generations of
stars to get to there and then all of
evolutionary history from there to now
to create a global intelligent
superorganism and how close we came time
and time again to not making it if it
hadn't been for an asteroid striking a
planet and destroying the dinosaurs we
wouldn't
if it hadn't been for the Toba eruption
reducing our diversity to a point where
we were so similar we could speak to
each other empathize with each other
understand each other we wouldn't be I
would argue in this great global
superorganism that we have created I
think it's entirely possible we are the
first and as Alfred Russel Wallace my
great scientific hero speculated at the
end of his book man in the universe
maybe it is our destiny to perfect the
human spirit in the vastness of the
universe but one thing I'm sure about
we're never going to find out if we if
we don't make the right decisions over
the next few decades because the global
human super organism newly formed is
threatening the basis of its own
survival thank you
[Applause]
question from Carter if the earth as an
organism doesn't have a brain is the
modern civilizational super organism
capable of having one
I guess being one in is that good or bad
news whichever way you answer it well I
I think I I think that we are forming a
sort of a global intelligence you can
see the way we're sharing ideas now and
coming to a common view and and that
gives us the capacity to send a strong
clear message to to gaya to the earth
and we did it with the Montreal Protocol
we decided to stop destroying the ozone
layer there was a single global message
so potentially we can do it and I think
that we have despite our selfishness and
our greed we have a very strong
self-preservation instinct and we have
an instinct to cooperate so I do think
that this this global intelligence could
become a global intelligence for the
planet but it needs time to mature it
needs time to develop forests at its own
it's barely newly formed you know we we
still have the remnants of tribalism
with us we still have immense poverty in
parts of the world we still face this
growing population but but I think we
could make it
wellyou've saith the Montreal Protocol
as coming together and managing the
earth Commons pretty well and that's a
great moment but you're you spend most
of your time on climate issues now yeah
it's and you're trying to get a carbon
tax in Australia and you're encountering
sort of the opposite of the moderate
program on Montreal Protocol you're
encountering enormous resistance say
more about that what's what's actually
going on here sure look I spent three
years dealing with board the Copenhagen
climate Council I chaired the council
and in the lead-up to the Copenhagen
meeting and a lot of people were
disappointed that Copenhagen didn't
produce a treaty a global treaty we who
were close to a knew that was
gonna happen a year out it was just the
differences would sleep great what was
your default if you knew it wasn't gonna
happen what were you then hoping for
well the Australian government was
pushing for this thing called the Accord
which is based on a trade negotiations
you know where each nation voluntarily
and it takes a series of actions that
help move towards free trade that's the
basis of the Copenhagen Accord and that
instrument signed at the last minute
through the intervention of President
Obama is one of the most important
things to happen in recent human history
because what it is done has now been
strengthened at Cancun and we've had 80%
of the emitting nations subscribed to it
so 80% of the emissions are covered
under the under the protocol the pledges
that are in place so far are enough to
get us 2/3 of the reductions we need to
avoid dangerous climate change so it's
not good enough but it's getting us in
the right direction
the big question now is honoring those
pledges and after we we abandoned or
disbanded the Copenhagen climate Council
we all decided we'd go back to our own
countries and make sure that we honor
the pledges so Australia's big battle
now is about honouring our pledge by
getting that legislation in place in the
u.s. here you you pledged a 17 percent
emissions reduction below 2005 level by
2020 I'm very pleased to say I met with
President Obama's climate adviser last
week and you are at minus 9 percent
already so you've already achieved over
half of that yeah and you've got more to
go despite the inaction and stupidity of
Congress if you'll forgive me I'll do it
was with economic some a disaster that
yeah but you you were going to have a
cap-and-trade system here in California
you know the the states are acting
there's a lot happening at the federal
level in terms of transport with can you
cafe standards and so forth and there is
a chance that you will actually achieve
that target despite the nice saying of
the right but it's interesting you know
when you think about that where the
opposition is coming from it's there is
a sort of an emerging mentality
right-wing mentality that's resisting
all of this stuff that's still stuck in
the odds survival of the fittest world
it still subscribes to the the sort of
neo-darwinian paradigm I think and and
that that's that's what that's what the
fight is actually a battle of ideas
so suppose Darwin and Wallace were here
what would they
the two of them be making of climate
situation well I think that the Darwin
would be saying show me the mind you see
of the evidence I'm not sure how it all
works you know
whereas Wallace would say well I could
have told you that a century ago
[Laughter]
question from Austin what do you think
about yo Wilson's recent renunciation of
kin selection in favor group selection
he got in big trouble with Dawkins over
that does the debate tell us something
about Gaia or our chances to you form an
intelligent superorganism yeah look I
think that the Wilson was right to
announce kin selection the mathematics
doesn't doesn't add up
but whatever the mechanism is that that
is creating this at a genetic basis and
it's happening between unrelated genetic
texture by the way like the mitochondria
in ourselves there are powerful forces
of work that that result from that cruel
and amoral mechanism called evolution by
natural selection that create the thing
we call love between human beings create
the bonds between species and the bonds
between individuals all of that's that's
an evolutionary outcome this sounds a
little warm and fuzzy to our eyes well
why should it this is a everything about
us every manifestation of life is a
result of evolution by natural selection
love is part of that yeah it's part of
the bond that keeps our civilizations
together that keeps out we can have love
of country love of our environment love
of other people I mean this is this is
part of the evolutionary outcome these
lovely super organism ik humans our
future eaters according to one of your
best books yeah that's right we've gone
through a period of being just that we
have and we haven't had awareness of
what we were doing most of the time you
know we've been very powerful but we've
been without wisdom and an understanding
of the way the global system works so
one way of looking at the future is to
say you know is our understanding of the
guy an organ is at the gay I'm gay an
entity you know that is happening at the
same time we are becoming evermore
powerful in terms of disrupting it so
it's a race really between perhaps you
know intelligence and technological
capacity or true intelligence and
without technology I was we're driving
over here you were mentioning your most
recent scientific paper was about the
mega fauna of Tasmania which you want to
tell that story of the Australian
megafauna died and then the tasmanian
Draco fauna died what was that about
well you know in in the past of fifty
thousand years ago every every continent
had a diversity of large mammal species
on it and they all vanished except for
that in Africa and it's long been
debated about why they went extinct and
we could had a great great opportunity
in Australia where we have an offshore
island called Tasmania and people
arrived there later than they arrived on
the mainland so I thought in Tasmania is
not that far from southern Australia so
the same climate regime runs through the
whole thing so I thought a great test of
this idea whether it was people or
climate is to look at what happened on
Tasmania if its climate they should go
the megafauna should go extinct at the
same time as they do on the mainland
45,000 years ago turns out that wasn't
the case the megafauna survived to
40,000 years ago in Tasmania so 5000
years longer they go extinct when people
arrived so people have been very
destructive you know and continue to be
destructive of ecosystems people with
Spears or what was actually the
mechanism of setting fire to thy habitat
well I think it was just direct hunting
I mean you know these big these are big
marsupials they're not the brainiest
creatures on the planet and of course
they've never seen a bipedal carnivore
before an ape they wouldn't run away
from us you know that it's interesting
naivety is important you read some of
the old whaling journals about whalers
where you know people will spear a while
and harpoon agraja and and as it's
thrashing about otherwise we'll come in
coming around it and they'll all be
speed as well and that's that's naivety
you know those whales are so big and
powerful if they figured out what was
going on they could have sunk that
whaling ship you know but they just
they'd they're naive of the threat big
brain naive guys yeah exactly honey
naive it is important well one of the
things it's intriguing me but going on
now is
idea of Pleistocene rewilding I'm
bringing back the the megafauna and that
we could have mastodons and mammoths
back in North America like we used to
and you know your book explained that
humans showed up here and that was it
for the megafauna except for a few
involves a little bit of genetic
engineering but we can get mastodons and
mammoths back is that a good idea or a
bad idea
well I think that rewilding is going to
be the great human initiative or one of
the great initiatives of the 21st
century mmm-hmm we're already seeing it
at the small scale and that that's you
know the small scale ranges from people
planting some indigenous plants back in
their local park to a state
reintroducing wolves or some species
that's been exterminated there and what
we're seeing that already happening and
part of the reason that people want this
we want to create more competent
ecosystems we want to preserve our
biodiversity and you know the hundred
terawatt budget that earth runs on is
degraded whenever we destroy living
systems its enhanced when we restore
them so the initiatives are already
happening whether we will have the
technology to reconstitute poly mammoths
in future or not
I don't know but I saw Straley and I go
fine would you like some of those back
the giant can grow I'd love them bad
love to see them but we have no DNA as
when extinct so long ago really don't
have a chance but you guys anymore you
can do you could do if we had the
technology to do Dodos because the DNA
is there you know just like with your
mammoths you can do it enjoy my deal
wolf can you get that one it's possible
in fact that we know it'll cost a bit of
a less than a million bucks today to get
the DNA code for that it's ordered it's
actually there in museum specimens start
a find yeah yeah we don't have the
technology to take that digital DNA data
they won't build a stylus on yet but you
know when we're talking about long now
you know a century from now I do you
have to set a fair bet we will
my sense is that it gives people hope
when rewilding occurs when the Wolves
come back yeah when the Buffalo come
back I suppose we could get passenger
pigeons back and thought of that before
Bhumika hood yeah sure and you know to
undo some mistakes is pretty attractive
it's wonderful it gives me hope and it's
one of the reasons I wrote about it and
because some of the battles were in now
they're so soul destroying like the
climate one you know you know there
won't be a moment of victory it's just
gonna be a hard grind my entire life and
your entire life as we gradually wind
back the emissions well you just which
sort of endorsed a radical approach to
bringing back certain kinds of life how
radical will you get and bringing back a
be nice steady familiar climate it's
geoengineering and your list of might
have to do sort of never dues I think
it's in the list of might have to do is
we hope we won't have to go but um no
one can guarantee the outcomes of this
great experiment that we're running now
with Earth's climate system so are you
watching that do you have a favorite you
know do you like to do sulfur dioxide in
the stratosphere or a biochar or what
well what I'm what I what I'm interested
in the moments getting some research
done so we can look at the unintended
consequences possible unintended
consequences of any of those
interventions we don't know enough about
any of them at the moment and we need
more research to guide us in our
thinking we also need to start laying
the foundations for agreed protocols for
the use because the last thing we want
one country going out and doing it
because they're facing a crisis when it
could have an enormous detriment to the
planet as a whole so we need some agreed
protocols in all of this as well so
there's a lot of basic footwork to be
done in geoengineering before we need to
consider which options are best no
country in the world is putting
government money into research on
geoengineering there's a little bit here
in there but it's not as big an
initiative as it should be
Australia for example is our our our
research national research organization
is looking at the impacts of sulfur
dioxide in the stratosphere on rainfall
patterns in the southern hemisphere so
that's a start but
you know one of the things I got from
your eternal frontier book that was
surprised to me there were a lot of
things that were surprised me in North
America who knew
well you described it as a sort of an
amplifier of climate change or maybe it
especially sensitive to climate change
you how does that work well it's it
seemed to me that the geography of the
continent was set up so that you've got
these mountain ranges running on the
east and west side of it and a big flat
plane in the middle of the continent
which is just a thoroughfare for weather
systems and you know you've got very
extremely cold air in the north and very
very hot moist air in the south and they
they they rampage across the continent I
call the treasures of the way down you
get tornadoes yeah great climatic
trumpet is what it is and and the
climate can change I mean I experienced
it when I lived here aloof tea for a
year and it was wonderful living in
Boston seeing a place go from what
appeared to my naive eyes to be a
tropical rainforest you know that was so
green and full of all these tropical
birds by the way as well it fly up there
to live there two months later I wake up
in bed thinking I haven't seen an ad or
a fly for some time now there's
something wrong with this place and then
these white stuff starts falling out of
the sky and you think actually this is a
very alien environment very different
and that that extreme change in weather
you know is part of it so is it more of
a north-south channeling forcing than in
Europe or Asia or other places
yeah well Europe's got the trent
mountain drains running transversely so
it's it's cut off you know and
Australia's just incredibly variable but
you know it explains a lot I mean I was
fascinated in this country why do all
look plants the trees have leaves kind
of vaguely shaped like my hand you know
they're often different families I
discovered why is it that in my country
they've all got leaves shaped like a
sickle they all come from different
families so the star and a sickle why is
it turns out that your leaves are the if
you if you stretch a membrane over a
structure like a hand shaped structure
that is the most cost-effective way
energetically to create a membrane
surface to capture the Sun or to do
anything and it's the McDonald's coffee
cups of leaves you chuck them away at
the end of the season which your plants
do they throw their leaves away I
couldn't believe it when I saw our
plants would never throw the
leaves away they're too valuable you
know these little sickle shape things
that are kind of hard and they resist
being eaten by insects and you know
because the nutrients in Australian
sauce are so limited that plants cannot
afford to lose their leaves we'll have
plants die if a hailstorm comes and
knocks a certain percentage of leaves
off the plant they can't survive this
grace but as he like check them all away
every year I'm thinking oh my god this
is a different country so is that why
your eucalyptus trees are so happy on
this continent that they astounded to
find good soil and something a standard
defined good sort of standard to be
without all of their predators as well
and then they've they've left all their
diseases and predators behind in
Australia you know how well you could
have stalk scraggly or in Australia some
things do try to weight them including
koalas and stuff so why does it go so if
we had a bunch of koalas we would be
able to check the you know the koalas
the cane toad of North America I'd say
exactly they said because I like candy
this stuff here these eucalyptus I love
it nice nutrient nutritious leaves you
referred several times to 100 terawatts
one of the questions is from anonymous
is what exactly requires 100 Tara Watson
how does that relate to you the constant
incoming solar energy sure well plants
capture about things but Humanity is I
understand users about what is it's all
16 terawatts yeah right a bad it's a
it's a small percentage here 16 so all
of human interest that's actually a
pretty large fraction of the whole
bloody life budget absolutely it's big
but it's about the proportion of the
brain to the body we 2 percent of the
mass twenty percent of the unit answers
the question if they're part of the
brain yeah yeah right so it's about the
same 3de 20 percent that's right yeah
yeah right so there's maybe there's
something in it or maybe it's
coincidence whatever it is 100 terawatt
budget comes from life capturing 4
percent of the sunlight that hits the
surface of the planet and that is all
all of that energy is put into creating
chemical imbalances between the three
principal organs of planet Earth right
so the rocks are out of balance
chemically with the oceans and the
atmosphere and and so is the atmosphere
with the oceans on a dead planet the
planet is equally
briam it is it is at chemical rest its
what the physics and the chemistry alone
would create a system at risk whereas on
earth this enormous energy budget is
used to creating disequilibrium so the
oxygen there so the atmospheres full of
oxygen the oceans have no minerals in
them the Earth's crust is full of all of
the dangerous minerals and carbon that
life's put there to keep it out of the
atmosphere I mean carbon is one of the
great imbalances you knows hardly any in
the atmosphere compared with the dead
planets right it's all in the wrong it's
all kept in the rocks so so that's what
the budgets useful
I'm answering 95% or 98% whatever it is
co2 high levels of co2 anyway in the
atmosphere and it's chemically at risks
what you'd expect like any dead planet
there will be a an equilibrium in the
chemistry of the rocks in the atmosphere
the question from amber Kerr who wants
to know that Amber's from UC Berkeley
you said we must eradicate poverty to
give people a longer timeframe the lower
discount rate yeah it is the rich people
on earth you have by far the biggest
environmental impact how do we get
around that conundrum
well we it's that that is the great
conundrum well because we won't slow
human population unless we create a more
effluent a poor and you know getting
people to give something up as the
hardest thing it's I've thought about it
I'm no expert in this area but I'm sort
of interested in what we use our wealth
for and that has changed over time we we
haven't always used it for conspicuous
display of self owned wealth I worked in
New Guinea for 20 years Stuart there
were societies up there where a big man
a man who wanted a big name would build
debt over time and then he would say to
people at a certain moment in time I
want to pick from every one of you and
he'd get a hundred or a thousand pieces
together and have an enormous peak feast
and distribute the meat and what he was
building could she can't bank meat like
you can't you can't preserve it he was
banking obligation by giving it away to
debt based form of society and in the
past we've had societies of potlatch you
know we've had in medieval Europe people
Kings would give away their wealth to
create cathedrals because they that was
a way of establishing a great that was
so the way we use wealth is important
and I I don't think that's a fixed human
thing I don't think the kind of current
greed that we have for material objects
sees is very long-term and I don't think
it's fixed I think it's a result of us
coming out of poverty fairly recently
that conspicuous display of wealth and
even net changing quickly you know the
old days of the cigar smoking boss you
know who was
of a way to drop dead at sixty of a
stroke you know these big car that's
check that's going where we are changing
all the time with this I don't know what
it's going to wind up but I know it's
changing well there you're in Australia
you guys are close enough to Asia and
South Asia and so on Indonesia to be
paying close attention to what's going
on there a whole lot of people are
getting out of poverty yeah in that part
of the world is this playing out are
they taking the longer-term perspective
on things as that happens what we're
seeing in places like China is people
using their wealth as conspicuous
displays so I mean I've been to be to
China to a banquets where people will
order a bottle of very expensive French
champagne or a number of them which
they'll drink and have no idea even how
what temperature to be drunk at and
obviously the taste is nothing it's the
fact they can afford it and display at
that scene so they're probably at the
stage that a lot of people were in the
night at in the 19th century early 20th
century in the USA you know
conspicuous display of wealth so with
that will be worked through as a society
as a whole though they are actually
responding so the good examples forest
cover 30 years ago in China forest cover
was at eight and a half percent it's now
at about eighteen percent because
they're getting effluent enough to be
able to be concerned about that and and
do large-scale rear forestation projects
so these things take time and change but
there is no doubt that you know you've
got to give people something to lose in
order for them to take a longer-term
view it's interesting in that regard I
was just looking in a Wall Street
Journal this morning there's now three
hundred over three hundred million
middle-class Africans and that is
something and prospect I think for great
hope yet and they're relatively
invisible Africa that you know serve
enough people kind of wrote off Africa
as a basket case and turned attention
maybe that's good and when we turn our
attention away these places get better
on their own yeah maybe there's a lot of
very serious charity and missionary work
and so on going on there but we don't
think of Africa the way we think of Asia
is sort of a worrisome competitor
ya know but you know if you think back
on on what you know Asia was like fifty
years ago very very different place it's
now you know China's gone through the
demographic transition in India is going
through it we can see the beginnings of
the demographic transition in
sub-saharan Africa now so Australia when
I was there with an American Indian wife
many years ago seemed pretty racist to
me oh yeah was he was terrible we we
have always had a fear of Asia
particularly because we're very close to
these massive population centers and
we've had a white immigration policy
that have kept them out
we've despised our own indigenous people
you know historically right but
something changed in Australian society
I would say in the 70s 70s maybe for
some reason perhaps the Vietnam War
changed at the first make excuse me
major non-european immigrants were from
Vietnam and there was a lot of fear
around that but it's it's Australia is
now a multicultural society you can go
into any of our cities and meet people
from anywhere on the planet sort of
passively or proud of it or out of that
place very very proud of it now yeah and
we're very ashamed of our past which was
appalling Lee bad actually
in terms of racism but it was a
xenophobia you know and we were you've
gotta remember we were almost invited by
the Japanese as well as a very real fear
was only you guys who saved us you know
we're very aware of it and grateful to
by the canal these guys the Marines
exactly the Marines downstairs no he's
not kidding no I'm not they're still
greatly esteemed and all of the Marines
who survived Guadalcanal got super laid
and that you know that almost caused the
Japanese to win it made of mine was
dismantling Japanese bombs and he found
a propaganda bomb full of these bits of
paper shaped like a dollar note on one
side of it was these Aussie soldiers
slugging up the Kokoda trail you know
we've made all over them and bullets
flying and on the other side was a scene
from an Australian bedroom with a couple
going hammer and tongs in a bed with an
American uniform hang on a bedpost
so that was supposed to disappear Edessa
Australian soldiers sir
history is wonderful yes Kevin Kelley
has a question is there a challenge in
having a superorganism in a set of 1 no
backup no redundancies is there a way to
add redundancy the guy on this by the
way is something in Lovelock rain into
you remember with biologists early on
that's right well that's right what the
argument about Jo was that how is
natural selection occurring because
there's only one don't know it doesn't
seem to be reproducing and I would I
would my response to that is that we're
still just dating we have not yet been
we have not got to puberty yet puberty
will occur when we colonize another
planet right it's it's an organism we're
looking at here into single organism
like becoming an organism but in terms
of whether there's backup systems I
don't think so I think we are going we
are going to become a single global
superorganism the benefits of
cooperation are so enormous that no one
is going to want to stay outside the
system or could stay outside the system
I'm afraid we have only have one brain
there will only be one there will only
be one global intelligence I think for
the planet this sounds kind of like
black helicopters from like one
government I'm sorry that's it says
standard right wing American paranoia
thing that the United Nations wants to
take over and all of us liberals are
helping that happen and the black
helicopters the United Nations are
conspiratorial a little blue helmets
happen yeah all right well look I
haven't mentioned world government once
I don't think we're ever going to have a
world government it's not in this it's
gone as far as we know so far it hasn't
been necessary all it's been necessary
is to have a mechanism to agree on how
we deal with with common problems right
so that's why I can't see a global
government working that sort of a
command and control economy it doesn't
work with that selfish upright Apes we
need democratic systems with all of
their tediousness but but that's the
only way we have of dealing with it
there are many systems of managing the
Commons and various fisheries
and things like that where it's not
strictly a government yeah makes it
happen but a set of agreements that all
the participants come to you and then
you deploy you know it's interesting to
be in the solar system with a planet
which is busily getting out of its life
infancy and there are other planets we
can sort of look at out of a corner try
and one of the things that surprised me
in James Hanson's book on the most
recent one on climate the storms of my
grandchildren he throws in the the Venus
option yeah and the Venus option is that
basically Gaia can't keep up and we go
to Venus which is a total greenhouse
planet with zero life on it it's hotter
on the surface than mercury which is
much closer to the Sun and I had not
heard anybody actually say we could
become Venus do you think we could
become Venus look that's a really really
good question and I think another DEATH
of all life is yeah that's right exactly
that's right you would have to say that
the earth system so far has withstood a
series of shocks over the last four
billion years which have been arrayed
swarming some yeah the continents
wandering around that's right
oxidation so that's not going to you
know anaerobic or aerobic life that was
a big deal
exactly so I'm not so concerned about
the extermination of life what I'm
concerned about is a weakening of the
productivity their planet to the point
that it cannot support this very
expensive greedy selfish global
intelligence right this we are the most
expensive item on the guy and menu by
far and we need a robust healthy
productive over the most active hmm
loose rainforests where you lose the
oceans there would still be some greedy
people around we're better than
cockroaches now at surviving sure but
look there are there are real concerns
with with this because if with the
Amazon rainforest a good example the
destruction of the Amazon rainforest
could lead
a positive feedback loop that puts us
negative a positive feedback loop that
puts you know a couple of hundred
gigatonnes of carbon into the atmosphere
because you know a lot of the
rainforests over the Amazon is generated
by the rainforest itself if you're not
then enough of it you know the climate
modeling says you could have a semi
desert there you know that the right
there's not enough rain fifty five
million years ago well what we're trying
to work out what happened fifty five
million years ago but the best analysis
to date suggests that there was an
eruption of methane from the sea floor
in the North Sea that put an enormous
animal see yeah it was these are
clathrates maybe present rates maybe
more conventional gas deposits but there
may have been volcanic activity kind of
like firing up a barbecue you know this
hot rocks down there and they they they
caused an explosion in there or a
heating of the the all of the the
petrochemicals then in the rocks they
are wrapped through the seafloor and
people have found a crater that they
erupt at formals craters and straight up
into the atmosphere and you get a
massive pulse of greenhouse gases an
instant speaking of temperature and you
know before you know it you've got
you've got lemurs living in the
rainforests of Greenland you know the
temperature spikes and it takes 10,000
years at least for the earth to start
cooling down again only 10,000 years how
long did it take for the answer I wonder
is this one of those abrupt climate
changes to be instantaneous it's like
this stuff already
well it's like once the once the
greenhouse gases in the air you've got
the warming occurring over over decades
or centuries it's kind of why on a
geological timescale it's pretty
instantaneous but this is an event that
happened 55 million years ago so it's
really hard to get that yeah fine you
you were we were talking earlier about
climate should say the Tim is is a
biologist in still practices but he's
been in the thick of climate stuff
professionally in a global scale for
quite a while now working in Copenhagen
and everywhere else and
you were saying that there's this kind
of oscillation that goes on between the
ocean controlling the atmosphere and the
climate and the continents controlling
the atmosphere in the climate how does
that story play out well one of the
mysteries of sort of the Gaian
regulatory system is that for the last
two million years we've been switching
from ice age conditions to interglacial
conditions as a result of a very tiny
change in the Earth's system it and that
what is controlling whether we're in an
ice age or not is a celestial factors
which include the the orbit of the earth
around the Sun the the the tilt of the
Earth on its axis and the wobble of the
earth on its axis and every hundred
thousand years or so those three cycles
conspire to create a cool summer in the
northern hemisphere because pointed away
from the Sun and yeah that's a bit
further from the Sun and it should be
you only get about it's about a tenth of
one percent at most of variation in
sunlight that's hitting at Leonard but
it's a very tiny initial trigger but
that causes an alteration in average
global temperatures for the planet by
five degrees from 15 back down to ten or
you know 9 to 14 wherever it is so
massive change why is that happening
you know one possibility is that the
earth system is not a single coherent
whole with a single objective if you
want in terms of regulation but that the
oceans like temperatures of 10 degrees
or less because at those low
temperatures you get circulation in
these 10 degrees Celsius or less that
Fahrenheit I know it's about 40
something yeah 40 renovates cold 50 yeah
so they like it really they like we use
a lot of crowdsourcing very good
calculations yeah but anyway they like
it very cold the oceans because then you
get circulation in the water column and
nutrients coming to the surface and you
optimize life in the oceans but on land
the old land-based life prefers that
around 23 degrees Celsius because there
you've got optimum conditions for plant
growth on land so it may be that this
this shifts from planet so in seem like
oceans probably have
majority rule yeah you'd think so but
somehow rather we kick out of that
oceanic control if that's what's doing
it quite quickly quite suddenly into a
warmer face we never get to 23 degrees
we're always you know 14 or so but it
seems to be kicked up towards that so
that's one explanation for for this some
almost like a bimodal condition of the
earth system now what's the future of
that I've heard it said that what humans
do now makes another Ice Age basically
impossible yeah look the cycle is a
hundred thousand year cycle
you know we're due or overdue no we're
not we're not really we should be on a
slow cooling but you know we're only it
was the last ice age only finished
twenty thousand years ago so we've got
about 80 thousand years before we'd get
back into those you know back into the
next deep Ice Age and kick back up it
look it's hard to say the dynamics of
the system are really complex and the
modeling that we're doing you know is
reasonable for a century but those
longer scale questions are really hard
actually to question the models have
been getting better well we get better
enough is it attractable
is attractively understandable system is
severely nonlinear system yeah it's and
climate interaction with life or just
starting to get models I gather that
include guy in mechanism yeah do you
think that that is saved by mid-century
this planet brain would have really
predictive models of climate you know I
do think so what we do yeah I think
that's possible the the the climate
science is developing incredibly quickly
and one of the best examples that I can
point to of that is that it was only
earlier this year in March that climate
scientists were able to point with a
high degree of confidence to the impact
of the warming trend on individual
weather events and the weather events
they looked at were flooding in Europe
and particularly the flooding in Wales
in 2000 and you know the Europe has a
density of weather stations now that are
sufficiently old that you can you know
by analyzing their daily got a great
data set and you can actually assign you
know probabilities of impact from the
warming on these individual weather
events and that is hugely powerful not
yet possible in places like the US as
far as I'm aware or Australia but in
Europe they can just because they've
gotten such good data yeah and in the
well the climate scientists are very
demanding I mean they really want a high
degree of confidence with this stuff
before they and that's the result so you
gotta have a good data set to show that
the shift has occurred and this has had
an impact if Schneider used to see that
anything less than 10 years isn't
climate yeah that's just weather that's
right yeah exactly
but we're now getting to the point we
can actually look at individual weather
events in the context of this warming
trend and what's interesting about that
of course is that opens up the whole
question of liability because it opens
the potential for someone saying well my
house that was floated there was flooded
because of your pollution and that as
that as that as away there's a global
problem is all the coal companies at
once yeah you might decide to sue the
sector you might decide to concentrate
on one of the big ones that say I'll
just take 10% because your pollution was
only 10% who knows how it's going to
work out in the courts I do not know but
I think that it's interesting to see
that the sciences came to the point now
of linking individual weather events
with the warming trend and where that's
going to go is anybody's guess but the
science keeps getting better year by
year the rate that becomes a very
detailed blame apparatus customs yeah
well potentially I don't know how I have
no idea how it would work out in the
courts it may not go anywhere but it's
just interesting that we're now
beginning to see I think that the
responsibility you know for individual
events so blamed on the shift do you
keep saying a new beginning and this is
a matter of hope this
we think in centuries these days and we
try to encourage thinking in centuries
how exciting and hopeful is this century
to you
well it's without that the century of
decision this is the century that human
populations going to peak we can see the
looming food crisis and the water crisis
and the energy crisis so we know that
what we do what this generation does and
what we do over the next 10 or 20 years
is tremendously important but I find it
really exciting because if you look at
the pace of change in the correct
timeframe it is very very fast and can I
just point out one trap we humans always
fall into is you know we look at the
24-hour news cycle we look at what's
happening day to day in our environment
and we can be driven to despair because
that is a bit like making an investment
in your retirement fund in the stock
market and then looking at the stock
market every five minutes to work out
whether you're going to retire wealthy
or poor right it's the wrong time frame
you've got a little longer time frame
and success is measured in the in the
climate arena on a decadal scale really
because it's a big problem you know just
think back six years no one had heard of
An Inconvenient Truth
yeah the climate scientists were pulling
their hair out about this problem and
yet the public was by and large and
aware of it since then we've had the
biggest meeting of Heads of Government
anywhere on the planet in Copenhagen
biggest meeting in the history of
humanity of Heads of Government right
they came together not to discuss
nuclear disarmament or anything else but
climate change we came out of that
meeting with an agreement called the
Copenhagen Accord there for the first
time bound developing countries in so
this is now a whole it's a global
agreement than we're getting towards and
we're now doing a really hard work of
turning the emissions curve down and
your country started on that you're at
minus nine percent you know it China
started on it my country has started on
it so where will be five years ten years
from now I don't know but I can see that
we're started the work and I think the
pace of change is only going to
accelerate as we start bringing the
renewable technologies to scale
and get vertical integration in the
industries and start getting acceptance
and start learning how to use those
intermittent sources of energy better I
don't know where we're going to be in
five years I mean electric cars are a
great example but I know things are
changing and I think rather than look at
the day to day the way to empower
ourselves and give ourselves the energy
and courage we need to go forward in
what is a very difficult task is to take
that five-year time frame you're long
now kind of guy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]